[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
thursday august 18th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
space is one area you tend to see a lot
of global cooperation
but now as tensions grow between some
space-faring nations there are calls to
find ways to protect satellites and the
information they might be gathering from
cyber attacks
so what should international standards
for satellite cyber security look like
european satellite experts and the
german government say that country's
guidance could be a good model
joining us to discuss what that model is
and why it may be needed is wsj pro
cyber security reporter katherine stepp
hi kathryn thanks for joining me hi zoe
thank you
so let's start with why cyber security
is something that the space industry
thinks it needs to think about
so different people i've spoken with in
the satellite industry have said that
there's a lot of cyber security work
that really needs to happen as the
industry's going through a pretty big
transformation right now and over the
last few years in the past this was
really dominated by government space
missions government contractors and now
companies in the last few years have
entered such as elon musk spacex and
other startups and it's continuing to
grow
so people say that in the future
satellites will be built with new
components and software that cost less
money
and will be easier to access so you know
more cheaper commercial products but
that comes with the risk that it could
introduce cyber security vulnerabilities
to some extent that's a problem that's
really common across lots of industries
as technology grows and and new types of
products become available they might
introduce new cyber security challenges
and people are just saying we need to
think about how to actually solve these
and secure satellites
yeah i mean we've seen that you know
here on the ground we've talked about it
on the show maybe a third party vendor
has a cyber breach and it affects
companies that weren't even really aware
that they were using some of it but is
there a reason you know apart from its
growth that the space sector thinks that
it needs to start making these changes
putting these guidelines in place now
it's a good question it's also a there
are so many different stages involved
there's a long development life cycle to
satellites and then you have people
communicating with satellites on earth
there are a lot of different points
where an attacker could
intercept communications with a
satellite or target you know ground
stations on earth or the satellite in
space so there are a lot of parts that
are vulnerable
in february there was a cyber attack on
a satellite operated by the american
company viasat
that targeted modems that were located
in ukraine so that was the day that
russia invaded ukraine and the attack
ended up knocking out internet
connectivity for thousands of people in
europe
and also affecting wind farms in germany
so the wind farms were still able to
operate but the cyber attack took out
the remote monitoring systems which just
made it really difficult for the
companies to know what was happening
with wind farms at that time
so the u.s and european countries later
said russia was behind that cyber attack
russia consistently denies that it's
involved in cyber attacks and that it
launches cyber attacks on the west
and people i've spoken with in the space
industry said well you know this is
something that's bound to happen again
in the future this is just one example
of what's possible
but it certainly brought a lot of
attention to satellite cybersecurity and
also to how important satellites are to
our daily life and how people rely on
them for many things
i mean we do
rely on satellites and the information
that they gather or provide
so much so what are these german
standards that are being proposed and
why would they help
so these german guidelines it's a
technical document it really spells out
basic cyber security steps that
companies in the satellite industry can
take and also common risk factors so it
goes through again the different parts
of that life cycle of a satellite
including things like when it's being
transported around from site to site and
when it's going through different types
of tests and then when it's in orbit
which can last for several years
one of the big challenges that also
these guidelines addresses is that
satellites can stay in space for 10 or
so years
and it's difficult and risky for
operators who are on earth to issue
security or system upgrades to a
satellite that's already in space
without introducing new risks it's a
delicate system that comes with really
complicated engineering challenges
it's not like engineers can just press a
button and start a security upgrade like
we can do on our smartphones or other
home devices are there any guidelines in
place now for cyber security in the
satellite or space industry
so there aren't the german cyber
security agency says that their
guidelines are the first of its kind to
really address the satellite industry
broadly there are security requirements
for government space missions
but the different experts and
researchers that i've spoken with who
work in the space say that there's a
real need for rules and guidance out
there for commercial operators around
the world
how is the international community then
reacting to the the idea that they might
follow these german guidelines or that
there need to be guidelines
everyone i've spoken with has really
emphasized the need for there to be some
kind of international consensus on how
companies in the satellite industry
address at least some of the basics in
cyber security because space missions
really often involve companies based in
different countries and the supply chain
is international
so the german guidelines even the german
cyber security agency itself says this
is really just a start we want to use
this as a basis to go and talk with our
partners in
other countries in the u.s and europe
and try to get some kind of
common version of this that we can all
agree on and the the private companies
that are involved in this industry are
they reacting in the same way the ones
that i've spoken with have said this is
really essential i think for some of the
bigger operators these might be some of
the things that they already do anyway
some of the kind of basic cyber security
things that they already think about but
they say this makes it easier for us to
go to maybe the other the smaller
vendors in our supply chain and say
do you comply with this and this rule do
you think about this kind of risk
because it's a document that they can
all refer to
all right that was our reporter
catherine stupp thanks so much for
joining us catherine thank you
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]